[Musique]
depuis combien de temps tu es question
nous deux
il ne vivait que pour lui même
et d'un coup tout a basculé
je t'aime
reste
hardy avait énormément de démons j'étais
jeune j'étais amoureuse j'étais
terrifiée et il essayait d'être meilleur
mois
j'arrête pas de m'entraîner dans mes
histoires déjà c'est pas juste
insight
je sais pas si je peux continuer à
lutter pour sauver lui au lieu de me
sauver moi même il faut qu'on prenne nos
distances pendant un temps tu peux pas
échapper à toi même juste en allant d'un
endroit à un autre tu le sais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais la guerre des enchères pour mon
livre je ne veux pas que les gens lisent
ces choses sur moi il s'agit de nous
quel est l'intérêt de tous nos galères
qu'on a traversées si on peut pas en
faire quelque chose qui aide les gens
c'est une histoire qui parle de partons
et d'amour inconditionnel une part de
nom c'est ce genre d'histoires kafteur
raconte haftar c'est mon voyage après
que je t'ai rencontrée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors tu vas te faire arrêter tu le sais
françois tu dois tirer t'étais pas là
quand elle avait besoin de toi et là tu
fait qu'empirer les choses
tu es en train d'épuiser mes dernières
bribes de self control t'es même pas
idée